is a bit big that's good
i don't know if i can see something hey
welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous videos you could
see we have two ruins on the land
one of them is this little kitchen right
here but up until now it's been very
hard to access because there are bushes
everywhere around it the building is
almost collapsing
so today's video we're gonna clean it
all up so we can go inside
take measurements and see what the thing
actually looks like
and we got a friend helping out so
here's liao hey
i'm liang and he's coming from porto to
help us out
and he's actually been involved in
pressure plastic since 2016
as one of the first to rebuild the
machines and tour around the coast to
make surf rack scrapers
and recently released a how-to on how to
make an electric skateboard from
recycled plastic
anyway no plastic today with chopping
bushes
[Music]
this orange brick building is in a
pretty rough condition it burned down a
few years ago
it's overgrown in brumbles and
surrounded by young mimosa trees
and it's actually located quite central
on the land so here's base camp
here's our future workspace and here's
the kitchen
yeah let's have a look down there to see
what it looks like
so yeah the building is in pretty rough
condition and let me show you a little
bit
what it currently looks like because
it's the last time we're going to see it
like this
so first off a lot of bushes everywhere
around
[Applause]
so here we have two cellars a bit
overgrown
but it's a natural granite and very cool
inside
so has potential
so the building is not structurally very
strong very scared to take out this
brick that everything is going to
collapse
so just leave it there for now and the
building burned down
a few years ago to a fire so that's why
now
you see a lot of roof tiles on the floor
because the roof collapsed
some parts of the roof are still
somewhat there
like here but the tiles are about to
fall down
soon and in general the building is
pretty roughly built and here you can
see
a hinge for the window to open pretty
roughly integrated
so we're not really sure what the whole
building looks like how strong it is and
what parts we can still reuse
so yeah it's time to clean it up and
discover what's underneath all of this
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's too nice and cool in here way
cooler isn't it
you could change the workspace here um
cool
okay underhole
there's mimosa everywhere yes
so i'm gonna dig some dirt out because
we found out that there's a floor here
and try and see with material and what
state the floor
is at so we see if we can use it
[Music]
look at this we never saw the side of
the house
make it getting there
a lot of fun we can do a raised bed here
and do some aromatics for the
kitchen
you can't go almost no it's
in the past it was a wooden floor you
had here
made with nails this one is nailed to
the floor
yeah still have nails here
so where do you think all the soil comes
from so because there's stone floor
underneath
someone just dumped the santee or so we
guessed that
we found there some nails and the wood
uh
nailed to the ground so we guess this is
like a
old wooden floor that with time we just
button
and became soil and mimosas loved it and
started growing and
the cycle continued till we had this
pile of
huge soil nutrient soil inside
the house so years of organic composting
and probably animals coming in
and dumplings of animals also helped
during the process why are you in here
it's overheating the machine or me
i don't know i guess paul yeah
welcome to the human fridge
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
perfect shape
while lou is quite busy finishing and
cutting all the brumbles
we will start cutting the
these mimosas which have been growing
since the past
4 years so 7 2017
and they are now leaning a bit at the
house and it's also difficult to go
around and access the house
so we will chop them down and drag them
out
of this place so we can start clearing
it a bit more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
great
i don't know if you guys see it but
after cleaning all this area we found
out that the house is super bent
[Music]
and that's gonna be a project
so we found a brand
big log with a place
full of concrete bricks could be a place
for
drinking water for the animals we don't
know
now we need to uncover it
oh an archaeological spending
we found an ancient knife
roman time that we think
you think it was made for that guess not
i'll have some pain in my back in a
moment
i guess but if you put a plank here
i can envision here beautiful seat
and water underneath just to look then
and cool
and finally we had a bit more to clean
up on the outside removing some burnt
beams that we found underneath the
bushes
probably from a big wooden structure
that used to be here
and at this point the entire floor is
covered fully with forms
and we try to remove some of it like
dragging them out but
it's a lot so we're just gonna let some
of it be as it is and hopefully it would
degrade on its own
so after this more detailed work the
outside was kind of ready
ready for the next step hey we just
finished
cleaning all the outside from the bushes
and the
many many moses we had we have here a
beautiful
water tank to feed the animals
that we found out and now we're going to
go to the inside and try and
clean it up okay guys so we have here
a lot of junk from jerrycans to
tiles and even old
rusty motors a lot of cleaning up to do
and a roof to take so let's start
um
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
hahaha
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
smokey [ __ ]
smoke effect so at this point the inside
and outside are ready and we were happy
the job was done and that was until rita
discovered something
we are trying to figure out what is
underneath this
we see this edge here which could be
only
a small step of concrete
but if we dig down if we continue
this is all concrete still there is a
point
where i cannot or i can
still lift this is all concrete
so yeah with our last bit of energy we
decided to clean up that bit outside
area
because it would make it feel much more
finished and cleared up
and actually also prevent a lot of thorn
from growing back so
it's the smart thing to do
all right so here it is now everything
is cleared up i'm tired so i'll just put
on some music and nice clips so you can
see the end result
[Music]
all right so now our kitchen is cleaned
up we can properly walk around it
go inside underneath and the main reason
to do this is to just take measurements
and analyze the building
first to just see how big it actually is
but also really to understand the
condition it's in because it looks
pretty rough
so it helps that we can now see what we
need to renovate what we need to rebuild
so for instance the roof looks pretty
worn out probably need to replace
the walls are pretty sketchy but maybe
parts reusable
the floor in the middle is kind of a big
question because
it feels kind of sturdy but it looks
very sketchy so i'm not sure
i'm also actually not really sure how to
analyze this so if you guys have any
tips or suggestions on how to figure out
the structural strength of the building
i would be very curious funny side fact
remember the video i made update 12
where we interviewed our neighbors
the guy with the bicycle at the end
he actually was born in this building
and the woman from the video fernanda
who's our neighbor
she has actually lived here a big part
of her life
i have a hard time imagining living in
this building because it's pretty bare
not many facilities in there but they do
say it was a bit more advanced so they
had some sort of wooden outside
structure so i'm kind of curious
actually what it would look like
but unfortunately no one here ever has a
picture i mean
i guess they didn't have iphones in
their pockets so
yeah i guess we just have to imagine
that and dream what this place
could become and if you have any tips
suggestions on that or feedback make
sure to
show it in this card but anyway we're
now really not renovating anytime
soon because we just want to analyze it
understand the thing better before we
start doing anything about it that was
it thanks for watching
special thanks to leah for helping out
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
thanks for watching see you in the next
video